wir machen weiter mit dem erschütternden
amoklauf in heidelberg gestern hier in
diesem hörsaal ist es passiert es ist
der große hörsaal platz für
172 menschen hier stimmte gestern mittag
ein 18-jähriger student mit zwei
gewehren in den saal und eröffnete das
feuer einer jungen frau schießt er in
den kopf sie stirbt drei weitere
studenten werden verletzt und wie sich
jetzt herausstellt hätten noch mehr
menschen verletzt oder sterben können
denn der täter hatte noch 100 schuss
munition dabei und er war entschlossen
zu töten das geht aus einer whatsapp
hervor die er kurz vor der tat an seinen
vater geschrieben hatte darin heißt es
laut polizei
dass leute bestraft werden müssen und er
möchte nicht auf dem friedhof fertig
werden sondern eine seebestattung
diese ihre nachricht schickte der
schütze vor seinem hörsaal laden tat an
seinen vater was trieb den 18-jährigen
zu dieser wahnsinnstat
die polizei geht auf motivsuche
fakt ist sein wohnsitz war ein mannheim
vorstrafen hatte er keine die zwei
gewehre hatte er sich ein paar tage
zuvor im ausland beschafft 100 schuss
munition hatte der killer dabei warum
hat er dann aufgehört hat da vielleicht
den getroffen den betroffenen wohl da
die getroffen die ihr treffen wurde das
kann ich ihnen nicht sagen aber er auf
alle fälle möglichkeit nachzuladen der
hörsaal der war natürlich in todesangst
ich sag mal so und hat sich wie
berichtet
dahinten niemand aufgehalten nachzuladen
doch es kam anders der 18 jährige
verlässt den hörsaal und richtet die
waffe gegen sich selbst
das vorstellen dass junge menschen nach
hörsaal angegriffen werden ohne dass sie
irgendwie darauf vorbereitet war
miterleben müssen die problemzonen und
kommilitonen
eines zumindest verstirbt das ist etwas
was man sich eigentlich als
familienvater auch was oberbürgermeister
gar nicht schöner vorstellen kann
ein schock für alle studenten an der
heidelberger uni vor allem für die die
in unmittelbarer nähe waren sie bekommen
jetzt psychische hilfe
versuchen dir irgendwie nachzuvollziehen
was im kopf dieses mannes vorgegangen
sein muss uns zugeschaltet ist dr bernd
rottweiler er ist facharzt für
psychiatrie guten morgen herr onliner
herum wollen an der polizeipräsident
stellt sich in dem beitrag den wir
gerade gehört haben die frage warum der
täter aufgehört hat obwohl er ja noch
100 schuss munition hatte und zeit
nachzuladen haben sie eine antwort
darauf
erst sichere antwort natürlich nicht
das ist ja noch relativ viel unklarer in
diesem fall insbesondere auch hat der
täter unter einer schweren psychischen
störung gelitten oder nicht aber er kann
sich gestört gefühlt haben zum beispiel
unwahrscheinlich ist dass er sich
besonders in dem zusammenhang und
sozusagen von weiteren taten
zurückgetreten ist das ist ja davon
auszugehen dass es irgendwelche äußeren
faktoren gewesen sind dienen dazu
geführt haben dass er seine tat nicht
fortgeführt hat
nimmt ein amokläufer denn in kauf dass
er bei einer tat wie dieser dann auch
ums leben kommt ja sehr häufig
der amokläufer ist häufig in einem
tunnel und ist auf die tat fixiert und
hat sich auch vorher normalerweise damit
auseinandergesetzt und nimmt das eigene
ableben ganz häufig billigend in kauf
jetzt haben wir gehört er hat kurz vor
der tat eine whatsapp an seinen vater
geschrieben hat angekündigt dass
menschen bestraft werden müsste hat auch
gesagt wie er bestattet werden möchte
spricht das für eine kurzschlussreaktion
oder sind amokläufe generell eigentlich
länger geplant
amokläufe bei denen dann waffen besorgen
muss und wie dieser täter die
offensichtlichen ausland besorgt hat
sind natürlich vorbereitet das sind
keine augenblicks taten
auch die whatsapp an den vater deutet
natürlich auf den abwägen des verhalten
hin das heißt aber nicht dass nicht
trotzdem die türkische störung
vorgelegen haben könnte welche art ihr
sie im einzelnen ist es schwer zu sagen
den täter kann man nicht mehr befragen
daher selber verstorben ist aber in
aller regel sind solche taten und mit
sicherheit auch diese taten die
vorbereitet sind geplant sind und deren
konsequenz noch frohe abgewogen wurden
sprechen über den täter sondern sprechen
wir auch über die opfer zum einen die
verletzten die es gibt zum anderen die
verstorbene und dann natürlich die
vielen studenten an der universität die
jetzt unter schock stehen wie können die
jetzt am besten mit dieser tat umgehen
ja das ist natürlich schwierig zumal die
konsequenz für den einzelnen sehr
unterschiedlich ist es gibt menschen die
sind lebenslang traumatisiert und andere
verarbeiten soll es geschehen nun
wichtig ist natürlich in kontakt zu
bleiben unterstützung zu haben
aufgefangen zu sein reden zu können mit
der trauer dem schmerz und der
verzweiflung auch der ohnmacht
aufgefangen zu werden und irgendwo
ankommen zu können aber ich habe gehört
dass dies in der zwischenzeit geschieht
und viele von den studenten
offensichtlichen betreuung sind vielen
dank dr rogan war und wir wollen jetzt
sprechen mit unserem reporter live vor
ort peter wilke ist in heidelberg peter
was gibt es denn für neue erkenntnisse
über das motiv
sandra das ist auch hier am ersten tag
nach dieser schrecklichen tat wir sind
immer noch die große frage die polizei
hatte gestern angedeutet dass die ersten
erkenntnisse auf eine beziehungstat
psychische probleme des täters hindeuten
aber das ist nach wie vor unsicher und
absolut ungeklärt die polizei auch
angekündigt dass sie jetzt das umfeld
des täters durchkämmen wird das läuft
jetzt aktuell es wurden wohl schon
wohnräume des täters in mannheim dort wo
eben gewohnt hatte durchsucht und auch
der eltern wir haben es jetzt schon
mehrmals gehört er hat ja den vater kurz
vor seiner tat wohl eine whatsapp
nachricht geschrieben in dem er
angekündigt hat dass menschen jetzt
bestraft werden müssten wofür auch immer
und im hintergrund können wir eben
diesen hörsaal sehen wo diese tat
gestern stattgefunden hat wo 30
studenten vor ort waren als der
18-jährige täter dort eingestimmt ist
und eben die 23 jährige studentin
getötet hat es gibt ja auch mutmaßungen
darüber dass sich täter und opfer also
die verstorbene 23-jährige kanten und er
deshalb auch danach aufgehört hat um
sich zu schießen hast du dazu neue
informationen
nein darüber könnte man nur spekulieren
warum es diese vermutung gibt ist eben
dass er nachdem er der frau in den kopf
geschossen hat seine tat abgebrochen hat
also nicht weiter geschossen hat und
eben das gebäude verlassen hat und sich
eben außerhalb dieses gebäudes hier auf
dieser fläche daneben selbst das leben
genommen hat aber dort könnte man jetzt
nur spekulieren da muss man die
ermittlungen der polizei abwarten eine
frau ist gestorben es gab auch mehrere
verletzte
wie geht es den
die verletzten haben streift schüsse ab
bekommen sind aber nur leicht verletzt
diese schüsse gingen wohl an rücken und
beinen aber eben nur leicht verletzt
also da besteht hoffnung auf eine
schnelle genesung da besteht wohl keine
lebensgefahr soweit zu den verletzten
und eben gab es aber trotzdem das
tragische todesopfer die 13 jährige
student waren die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen an der
universität denn deiner meinung nach
auch ausreichend oder im ja gibt es
verbesserungsbedarf
ich kann das schwer beurteilen ich bin
kein experte aber es gibt seit gestern
hier ja schon eine leichte diskussion
darüber ob die sicherheitsvorkehrung
wirklich ausreichend war die studien die
uni leitung hat relativ schnell gesagt
dass das gut funktioniert habe dass alle
mitarbeiter und studenten hier auf dem
campus innerhalb von weniger minuten
nachdem nach der tat informiert worden
seien und in sicherheit gebracht worden
seien also alle sich in sicherheit
bringen konnten weil sie so schnell
reformiert und sein gestern sind dann
aber auch erste stimmen von mitarbeitern
und studenten laut geworden die gesagt
haben das war nicht so wir haben konnten
auch noch während die tat lief kurz nach
der tat ungehindert hier in diesen engen
bereich rund um den hörsaal am
botanischen garten hier hinkommen ohne
dass er daran gehindert wurden wir haben
erst später durch die polizei dann sehr
viel später eine bis zwei stunden danach
davon erfahren also da deutet sich an
dass da wohl doch nicht alles ganz glatt
gelaufen ist bei den
sicherheitsvorkehrungen informationen
von peter wölke vielen dank nach
heidelberg und wir schauen wir wie das
ganze aus polizeisicht aussieht sandra
schmidt ist professorin für polizei und
sicherheitsmanagement und sie ist jetzt
zugeschaltet frau schmidt die polizei
war innerhalb von weniger mit wenigen
minuten vor ort worin liegt für die
einsatzkräfte die besondere
herausforderung bei einem amoklauf
beim bei einer amoktat besteht eine
akute lebensgefahr für alle personen die
sich im unmittelbaren umkreis des täters
oder der täterin befinden und das wissen
auch polizisten und polizisten sie
selber agieren also in einer absoluten
gefahrenzone einen absoluten
gefahrenbereich und sie wissen auch dass
ein schnelles intervenieren hier
erforderlich ist um die amoktat zu
beenden wie sieht dieses intervenieren
genau ausgehen die beamten dann auch
sofort rein ins gebäude
ja hier ist unverzüglich alles in die
wege zu leiten das ja die tat des täters
angehalten wird es geht also tatsächlich
darum hier den täter handlungsunfähig zu
machen dass setzen dann auch voraus oder
das führt mit sich dass polizisten und
polizisten entgegen ihre intension an
opfern vorbeigehen müssen an getöteten
menschen vorbeigehen müssen der fokus
liegt hier auf den täter
wenn sie sich das anschauen was man weiß
über die tat gestern könnten sie sagen
das ist eine in
anführungsstrichen ein typischer verlauf
einer amoktat gewesen
das was wir aus geologischen forschungen
zur phänomenologie von amoktaten kennen
das spiegelt sich hier nahezu wieder
also bezüglich des täters
einzelgänger mit entsprechenden motiven
möglicherweise familiäre soziale
probleme persönliche probleme psychische
störungen aber auch das motiv rache was
wir als solches can gut vorbereitete
sehr akribisch vorbereitete tagen die
täter haben ortskenntnisse sie haben
bezüge zu den personen und die taten
finden nicht spontan stadt sind geplant
und das was hier in heidelberg gestern
passiert ist ist sozusagen das was auch
die kriminologische forschung zu
amoktaten kind frau schmidt dennoch
etwas untypisch was auch wirklich viele
fragen aufwirft ist die tatsache dass
der täter aufgehört hat zu schießen
obwohl er noch 100 schuss munition
gehabt hätte was könnte ihrer meinung
nach dafür der grund sein
ja das ist rein spekulativ jetzt nur zu
beantworten tatsächlich kann in erwägung
gezogen dass er aus seiner perspektive
heraus die tat verändert hat also
vielleicht richtete sich tatsächlich
seine tat gegen nur eine bestimmte
person oder gegen bestimmte wenige
personen und danach war sozusagen die
tat für ihn beendet so dass er sie dann
finalisiert hat mit der selbsttötung wie
wir mittlerweile wissen dass es denkbar
aber auch das prinzip der störung
möglicherweise
hat er mitbekommen dass die polizei mit
auf der anfahrt ist die polizei war sehr
sehr schnell auf den weg zur universität
also es gibt viele gründe warum das so
sein kann und da müssen wir warten was
quasi die ermittlungen jetzt bringt
natürlich gut dass es nicht noch mehr
opfer gegeben bemerkenswerte noch ganz
kurz zum schluss dass er ein 18-jähriger
sich im ausland mal eben zwei waffen
besorgen kann
das ist absolut bemerkenswert aber habe
es ist mittlerweile die realität auch
die waffen beschaffung im datennetz
beispielsweise ist heute relativ
unkompliziert möglich und das ist das
womit wir uns thematisch beschäftigen
müssen
vielen dank frau professorin sandra
schmidt für diese einschätzungen